- [Announcer] Please
put your hands together
for Danielle Perez. (audience cheers)
- You guys, keep it going
for those strong gentlemen.
Keep it going for them.
Lifting me on stage.
I'm gonna hit them up
for a foot massage later.
It's gonna be tight.
When I'm on stage, and I'm performing,
I feel really powerful.
What I'm saying is being telegraphed
to all these people that are there
to hear my story and be exposed
to, you know, a Latina who's disabled
and in a wheelchair.
It's just a really important thing
to be on stage representing that.
(instrumental hip hop music)
My name is Danielle Perez,
and I'm a stand-up comedian.
Performing stand-up comedy while
using a wheelchair is
a bit of a challenge.
First of all, people are always a little,
they're just thrown off.
They don't really get
what's going on. (giggles)
I'm really excited to be here tonight,
just debuting my new look,
which is aggressively fat,
yet still very judge-y.
(audience laughs)
I started comedy three years ago.
I realized I loved doing comedy
after my first open mic.
People laughed at me,
and that felt so good.
Like, I wanted to hold on to
that feeling forever,
and I was like, "I need
to do more of this."
I'm a big girl, but I can tell
that I've gained a little bit of weight
because people keep asking me
if I have diabetes, which is really rude
because I was hit by a
train. (audience laughs)
I've gone through a lot of dark things.
Eating disorders, depression,
I lost my feet when I was 20.
I definitely use comedy to
speak about those things,
but also to entertain, and through that,
find healing in myself.
(contemplative piano music)
I think that comedy is really helpful tool
in healing and bringing people together.
When you see someone on stage that is
sharing a story or telling a joke,
and you're like, "Oh, I get that.
"I do that, too," it unifies and it brings
people together, and
it's a form of catharsis.
I ghosted on my therapist
about two years ago
but realized I should get back into it
when I started daydreaming
about walking into traffic,
and I don't have feet. (audience laughs)
I think the message that I want to put out
in the world is that
it's okay to be yourself.
It's okay to be weird and different.
You're only given one
opportunity in this world.
So, make it the best you can.
(instrumental hip hop music)